tout ce que j'ai ressenti de plus
agréable de plus extraordinaire et ben
je l'ai connu en Tunisie t alors ici ici
j'ai l'impression que c'est c'est c'est
pas que c'est faux mais c'est c'est dans
saakarine et Tunis c'est du pur
[Musique]
sucre il était une fois une ville qui
s'appelait Tunis on l'appelait Tunis la
verte il y avait des Juifs des Arabes
des Italiens des Siciliens des Maltais
et puis des
Français Tunis c'est mon enfance c'est
les palmiers c'est le tramo c'est la rue
la faillette c'est le jour de Kipour
chez mon grand-père quand sa maison
devenait une synagogue la rue lafillette
toute entière venait chez nous Tunis
c'est la calèche avec les chevaux qui
venaient nous chercher au port sous le
soleil quand le bateau arrivait de
Marseille c'est le manège au belved
c'est la balanoire avec mes sœurs sur le
balcon
Tunis c'est l'heure de la sieste les
après-midis d'été l'odeur des citrons
doux Tunis et la plage la Goulette
keredine les glaces de La Marsa les
parfums de Monsieur
[Musique]
Hanoun Tunis c'est ma mère c'est aussi
mon premier
amour Lucy tu te souviens quand tu
habitais rue lafillette en face de chez
ma grand-mère oui bien sûr que tu voyais
tout par la fenêtre tu me racontes un
peu j'ai un souvenir tellement touchant
de ta grand-mère que je pourvais en
parler pendant des
heures CIT très très gentil ta
grand-mère j'ai gardé un très très bon
souvenir c'était comment la rue
lafillette la rue lafillette c'était une
grande une grande cétait c'est pas une
rue on pouvait dire que c'était une
avenue elle était bordée de palmier des
deux côtés il y avait des maisons
cossues comme celle de ta grand-mère
avec un étage et la terrasse
au-dessus et de l'autre côté il y avait
de d'autres immeubles alors où il y
avait trois quatre étages et moi
j'habitais un de ces immeubles juste en
face de ta grand-mère tu te souviens
quand les gens ils s'appelaient par les
fenêtres ah oui les gens s'appelai par
les fenêtres on appelait les gosses il y
avait même des marchands en bas des
icier alors ceux qui habitaent le 3è
étage descendaient un coufin attaché à
une corde et tout haut du balcon il
disait voilà tu me mets un kilo de
semoule tu me mets une barre de savon tu
me mets à litre d'huile et il faisaient
leur commission par le balcon si je te
dis Tunis qu'est-ce que tu me réponds h
je te réponds mon
enfance je te réponds mais probablement
mes racines ce que je ressens de de très
profond de très de très ancien le lien
avec avec tout tout le passé de ma
famille oui c'est je crois que c'est ça
que ça évoque surtout et une petite
enfance qui a été très heureuse dans un
pays
ensoleillé où il faisait bon vivre je
[Musique]
crois Tunis c'est les trollébus on
s'accrochait derrière pour aller au
lycée nos parents ils nous déposaient à
l'arrêt de du trollébus et quand le on
leur disait ouais salut on va prendre le
trollébus on est sérieux et tout et
quand le trollébus il arrivé on le
prenait pas on s'accrochait
derrière Tunis c'est
euh c'est le jour de mon départ j'étis
voir dire au revoir à tous mes copains
et puis à un moment donné je me je me
suis dit il est tard ils m'ont
oublié et c'est la course qui m'a amené
de chez mes copains à la maison de la
plage où on habitait et pendant toute
cette cour je me suis dit je suis sûr
que mes parents ils m'ont oublié
et je pleurais parce que j'étais
triste de partir et je pleurais parce
que j'avais peur qu'il m'oublie quand je
suis arrivé bien sûr il m'avait pas
oublié je me suis mis dans la voiture je
me suis recé dans la voiture j'ai plus
bougé jusqu'au moment du
départ pendant des millénaires les Juifs
ont vécu en Tunisie et puis un jour pour
eux ce fut
l'exil il y a eu l'indépendance en
Tunisie et là quelques juifs tunisiens
ont décidé de
partir c'est après au moment des
événements de
Biserte que le malaise a
commencé mais le plus difficile ça a été
la guerre des Six jours les magasins ont
brûlé la synagogue a brûlé les Juifs ont
pris peur ils sont
partis cette cassure entre Tunis et
Paris moi je l'ai connu très tôt j'avais
5 ans à Tunis je préférais Paris à Paris
je rêvais de
Tunis aujourd'hui à travers ce film je
cherche Tunis je veux savoir comment
vivaient mes parents mes grands-parents
mes arrières-
grands-parents et là c'était où là ça
c'est à Paris arrivve à Paris c'est le
jardin Luxembourg je crois ou et déjà
déjà vous étiez en en voyage oui il av
pas beaucoup de gens qui partaient comme
ça non
mon père voyageé deux fois par an et là
il était avec qui attends je vais voir
un petit peu de près c'est joli ça ça
c'est Vitel tu vois ça c'est Vitel ce
sont des amis de Vitel c'est encore un
départ il y a toujours des départs ah
oui tous les étés nous
partions mon père portait son ch tu vois
son chapeau toujours
[Musique]
tordu très sympathique
tu avais quel âge là j'avais à peine 16
ans je faisais du tennis déjà ah oui
bien sûr tu vois c'est au belveder hein
très joli c'est un belv c'est un petit
parc c'est tout c'est un petit là il y a
ple de fleurs aussi ça c'est à la plage
c'est une maison à la plage à quelle
plage bah la Marsa toujours c'est la ça
c'est la
résidence de Gen des bonjoir Lucy
raconte-moi ta
maman ma mère était d'abord très jolie
elle était très coquette très jolie elle
aimait beaucoup ses enfants
et et j'étais très bien avec elle parce
que je sentais qu'avec mon père il
formait un couple très uni et très
aimant
et quand quand quand tu es devenue un
peu plus grande et que tu qu'il fallait
marier les jeunes filles comment
c'était
c'était tu as dit tu as bien dit le mot
il fallait marier les jeunes filles
parce qu'on ne se mariait pas toute
seule on les marié c'était très rare
quand quelqu'un quand des jeunes
faisaient faisaient un mariage d'amour
c'était très très rare alors pour toi
comment ça s'est passé moi j'étais
l'aîné et je devais obéir à mes par et
comme j'étais l'aînée j'avais des sœurs
après moi il fallait absolument que je
me marie qu'on me marie la
première ma mère elle m'a raconté par
exemple queelle faisait de la peinture
et que elle elle aurait voulu être
peintre elle disait à son père et à sa
mère moi j'ai envie d'être peintre quand
je serai
[Musique]
grande mais alors il y a des choses que
vous auriez pu faire que vous n'avez pas
fait ah oui ah oui ça on a été refoulé
je te raconte pas c'est tout tout tout
nos passions tout ce que dont on avait
envie de faire tout ce qu'on avait envie
de faire on n'a pas pu le faire est-ce
que tu aurais rêvé de faire si tu avais
pu faire un métier moi je je rêvais je
enfin je rêvais c'est toujs ça reste
toujours dans dans le domaine du rêve
mais je rêvais d'être
avocate parce que j'avais cette chose là
parce que on nous a toujours inculqué le
défenseur de la veuve et de l'orphelin
tu vois j'étais très très près des
enfants et très près de tout et j'avais
envie d'être avocat d'ailleurs mon père
disait toujours à ma mère il dis comment
pourquoi tu veux la
marier moi je veux qu'elle poursuive ses
études qu'elle devienne avocate qu'elle
continue son piano et ma mère dit non
non non non non non si elle va continuer
elle va être trop instruite elle va être
trop exigeante et personne ne lui plaira
donc l'instruction ça rend c'est plus
plus lucide en même temps ouais bien sûr
et plus libre ce qu'il fallait pas
fallait pas être libre fallit pas être
Lucy c'est un peu toute nos mèr et
souvent j'ai pensé que cette liberté
refusée avait dû leur rendre bien
difficile cette arrivée à
Paris et alors quand tu es venu à Paris
qu'est-ce qui comment ça s'est passé
quand je suis venu à Paris en 61 ça a
été
un chamboulement terrible
c'était c'était pas pareil du tout
c'était une autre vie on était venu en
France je connaissais un peu la France
mais je n'ai jamais vécu des mois tu
vois je venais en je venais avec mon
mari pour 15 jours pour 20 jours mais
venir définitivement comme ça ça été
presque la destruction totale la vie
avait complètement changé alors qu'on
était à Tunis dans les an avec on était
servi on était aidé on avait la voiture
on était très très bien et puis ici il
fallait tout recommencer on était pas on
était éta pas très vieux on était pas
très jeune on avait moi j'avais 43 ans
quand je suis venu
ici alors tu Tas tu as travaillé comment
tu as faitment début au début j'étais
complètement déphasé
j'étais je pensais à mes enfants qui
manquaient enfin presque de tout et
c'était problématique et je pensais pas
du tout à travailler je n'étais pas en
mesure de en état de travailler je me
[Musique]
souvi je cherche aussi ce que sont
devenus mes copains d'enfance Joë Pez
max Catan Raoul Marec Carlo Monique
Eveline Yona
Rafo un amour qui fut
perdu
ce tu VO
ver bien sûr bien
sû
B je image image déchiré à
recoller chaleur d'un lieu sûr ou
illusion d'un espace
reconstitué ces visages je les connais
tous il me parle de mon
enfance c'est ici et ailleurs que Tunise
doit
survivre pas le c'est pas un problème de
vin c'est qu'on aime se rencontrer un
grand problème et toi tu es un pied noir
Algérien et tu adorees nous rencontrer
pourquoi mais non parce que ça fait 25
ans que je suis ici 25 ans c'est la
seule communauté que j'ai retrouvé la
communauté mais dis-moi tu arrives chez
nous comme ça et tu arrives et tu te
sens bien et tu as éliminé tous tes
copains d'enfance pour être avec nous
alors raconte unu les Tunisiens ce que
vous avez vous avez un instinct grégire
grégire vous êtes grégire non vous vous
on se rass parceon aim se revoir on aime
se revoir algéri on est des
invididualistes c'est ça qui va tirer
vers on est en bande vivre en bande de
trava de retrouver tu crois c'est pas
voil c'est tout
mais qui se souvient de la rue la
faillette moi toute notre jeunesse qui
se souvient non tu étais pas toi tu
étais
je et
tout la R laette kikino kikino c'est les
gens voil monsieur où tout est sorti de
là c'est une rue c'est une rue où tout
est sorti de là le centre le centre de
Tunis
citéit comme E à
par à
Tunis par
oui ben moi je vais te dire une chose à
Paris je suis très heureux et j'ai tout
trouvé à Paris mais pour moi Tunis c'est
irremplaçable mais comment ce que j'ai
laissé à Tun d'ailleurs je flash de
temps en temps qu'est-ce que je me
rappelle Rob je me rappelle le cireur je
me rappelle mon épicier du coin et tout
ça c'est irremplaçable les meilleurs
moment les meilleurs moments de ma
jeunesse tout ce que j'ai ressenti de
plus agréable et de plus extraordinaire
et ben je l'ai connu en Tunisie à Tunis
tu alors ici ici j'ai l'impression que
c'est c'est c'est pas que c'est faux
mais c'est c'est dans saakarine et Tunis
c'est du purure
sucre j'étais à l'école et à l'école il
y avait un arabe Hamadi un Italien péino
un maltais et tout le monde lorsqu'on
était sur le banc d'école avant de faire
n'importe quoi la maîtresse disait
attention vers saintori c'est ton
grand-père ta mère c'est la France alors
dans toute mon angoisse j'ai dit mais
merde je vais rejoindre ma mère je vais
aller en France je vais la revoir ma
mère et d'un coup mon angoiss est un peu
tombé je suis revenu en France et ben en
revenant en France j'ai vu ma mère mais
même ma mère oui ma mère elle a dit mais
c'est ça mon fils pourquoi il parle pas
comme moi c'est drôle il a pas les mêmes
heurs que moi il a rien et moi aussi
j'ai dit c'est ça ma mère il faut que je
rentre avec une carte il faut que je
rentre avec ça mais petit à petit le
rapprochement s fait elle est l' accepté
tu vois que je dois voir mes amis je
dois vivre avec vous qu' me font cette
chaleur tu comprends qu' me faut tout ça
mais c'est de la blague si je suis là ce
soir c'est vraiment je me sens
tunisien le bateau quitte le port
l'avion l'aéroport mollement je m'end
dor he de rester chez moi le bateau
prend le large la vie grogne de rage il
laisse derrière eux ce pays merveilleux
Tunis Tun Tun Tun Tun Tun Tun Tun tu
pleures ma minette ton fils il est parti
laissant sa maisonnette quit en son beau
[Musique]
pays
Tunis c'est la plus belle ville du monde
Tun c'est plus grand que New
York pour moi il y a Tunis Paris Rome et
Jérusalem
Tunis
c'est tu te rends compte ce que c'est
Tunis Tunis c'est
magnifique pour moi c'est magnifique
parce qu'il y a des gens quand je leur
dis Tunis tu peux pas savoir comme c'est
beau ils vont à Tunis des copains des
journalistes et ils reviennent il me
disent mais bon c'est beau mais il y a
pas de quoi se manger la tête comme tu
le fais toi il y a plein de papier gras
dans la rue et tout je dis oui mais
c'est ça qui est
[Musique]
beau
Tunis c'est la
sieste sais ce que c'est la sieste la
sieste quand il as mangé bien bien mais
tu sais tu vas t'éclater tellement tu as
bien mangé puis après tu vas doucement
te traînant il faut qu' a qu' la fasse
pas très important donc il continue à
parler il parle doucement pour pas te
réveiller parce qu'ils savent que tu
dors et toi tu dors pas vraiment et tu
es dans la chambre les volet sont fermés
tu a le soleil qui passe à travers les
persiennes tu sais et es tout nu dans
ton lit avec les draps frais et tu
t'endors à moitié et tu entends les gens
qui disent fais attention il dort ne
fais pas de
bruit ça c'est
[Musique]
extraordinaire
Tunis tu veux que je te dise sur Tunis
Tunis c'est
c'est c'est une manière d'être tu
comprends tu vois j'étais en Algérie il
y a pas longtemps et ben Alger c'est
beaucoup plus beau que
Tunis objectivement c'est beaucoup plus
beau c'est une belle ville blanche au
bord de la mer c'est c'est magnifique
hein mais moi je trouve ça moins beau
que Tunis tu sais pourquoi parce que
Tunis c'est Tunis parce que Tunis c'est
c'est mon enfance c'est toujours plus
beau ton enfance les jeux Tunis ont
tendance à cristalliser leur mémoire
leurs souvenirs et je crois que les
juifs tunisiens qui veulent continuer à
être juif tunisien devrai d'abord se
rendre fréquemment en Tunisie ils le
peuvent et mais également s'informer de
ce qui se passe en Tunisie aujourd'hui
essayer de d'avoir des contacts charnels
physiques avec la Tunisie avec les Juifs
qui sont encore en Tunisie avec les
Arabes tunisiens avec les Arabes
musulmans
et et se dire nous avons vocation à
vivre ensemble tu pris à où tu as pris
où tu as pris à
Tunis cétait le champion Tunis Mo
c'estis
jouer
m il
Estur bille mon est-ce que ça représente
Tunis
je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas parce que je me pose
la question de savoir si Tunis plutôt
les juifs tunisiens à Tunis est-ce que
c'est vraiment
Tunis alors Tunis ça n'est pas Tunis
Belleville et momart ça n'est pas Paris
les juifs tunisiens à à Paris dans les
quartiers qu'ils ont qu'ils ont forgé
qu'ils ont créé ça n'est pas Paris mais
ça n'est pas Tunis et à Tunis ça n'était
pas Tunis non plus
alors où
sont-ils ils sont un
peu ils sont un peu eux mêmes finalement
ils étaient peut-être même dans les
getos et les G c'était peut-être une une
pièce une petite maison avec beaucoup de
monde beaucoup d'enfants une grande na
blanche un soir par
semaine et là c'était ni Tunis c'était
ça n'était pas Paris non
plus
c'était c'était une certaine façon de
vivre juif mais qui était complètement
différente de la façon de vivre juif
dans un autre pays même un pays voisin
comme le Maroc l'Algérie à forceri comme
euh les autres
pays où ont habité les
Juifs alors les juifs tunisiens ne sont
pas des Tunisiens
ils ne sont pas des juifs ils sont juifs
tunisiens c'est une sorte
de synthagme figé finalement est
absolument c'est absolument
indissociable les deux propositions sont
intimement mêlées alors être juif
tunisien ce ce concept tout à fait
précis et bien est-ce que ça a besoin
d'un territoire madame comment
allez-vous bonjour ça va qu'est-ce qu'il
vous fallait euh je voudrais des
produits rock impossible comment
impossible je l'ai commandé hier
alors je sais pas si tu as déjà pris ça
je te marquer tu as déjà pris ça par
jour bon alors je vais te marquer sur
les bois je préfère hein trois par jour
pourquo on va perdre l'accent ça fait
partie de nous ça fait partie de moi
c'est un acquis c'est un trésor c'est un
héritage l'accent il est merveilleux
pourquoi on le perd celui qui me dit il
faut perdre l'accent en venant en France
bravo c'est parfait en fait ce qui nous
manque à nous juif tunisien c'est comme
dit Sart la vertu de nos ancêtres on n
pas la vertu de nos ancêtres parce que
bon on a pas de terre on a pas une
maison de campagne on pas donc on se
rabat un peu sur ce qu'on avait à nous
on a pas donc on de notre de notre mode
de vie qu'on a vécu en Tunisie alors les
fêtes se passe bien très bien
j'appartiens moi à une catégorie de gens
qui ont quitté la Tunisie disons il y a
une vingtaine d'années dans les années
60 ça a été un petit peu la folement
tout le monde est parti et cette
catégorie de gens a mis un un certain
nombre d'années une vingtaine d'années à
mon avis pour se ressaisir bon on a on
s'est marié on a qui a un appartement on
a eu un métier et au bout de cette
vingtaine d'année on a commencé à se
poser des questions et je dois dire que
c'est des questions qui ont été posées
surtout par no enfants qui ont dit qui
ont commené à se dire bon mon petit ami
en classe à une grand-mère dans le
périgor l'autre va en vacances dans le
Poitou et alors nos enfants ont commencé
à nous dire mais nous d'où est-ce qu'on
vient qui qui est-ce qu'on est
finalement où où sont nos nos
grands-parents pourquoi est-ce qu'on va
pas le dimanche comme eux euh à la
campagne et alors là on a commencé à se
dire mais c'est vrai finalement nous on
on est quoi on est des Juifs de Tunisie
et on a tout oublié on est parti dans la
précipitation on n' pas gardé de
témoignage de tout ça oui alors gros
juif bien entendu c'est parce que à
l'époque au début du siècle les
photographes avaient tendance à
photographier les grosses femmes juifes
qui pour les personnes qui envoyaient
ces cartes notamment les soldats qui
étaient envoyés en Afrique du Nord et
ben pour ces gens-là les gros Juifs
c'était un une photo particulièrement
intéressante disons exitante mais il y
avait quand même d'autres choses par
exemple prenez cette fille de juive
c'est quand même très jolie elle est
belle très jolie fille celle-ci qui qui
est d'ailleurs marqué belle jeune
tunisienne et on peut dire belle juif
tunisienne qui qui est très jolie alors
là il y a le chapeau comme c'est
justement les les femmes juifes
tunisiennes se distingu des femm arabe
par ce grand chapeau pointu qui
s'appelait La koufia qui est une sorte
de Hin qui est distingué donc des femmes
arabes qui avaient elle un chapeau
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus restint
beauoup plus petit et là on peut voir en
plus de ça la la la superbe tenue de
cette femme juive et dis-moi ta
grand-mère elle avait ça absolument ma
grand-mère avec ce ce chapeau
malheureusement en partant de Tunisie on
a abandonné beaucoup de choses y compris
le chapeau de ma grand-mère puis alors
il y a également les femmes juifes qui
exerçaient certains métiers comme
danseuse comme
chanteuse c'était pas honteux d'être
danseur non c'était un métier bon bien
entendu
on pouvait les montrer du Doig dans
certaines familles mais beaucoup de
femmes ont gagné leur vie sont devenu
célèbres comme Habiba Messica en
devenant comme ça des artiste de variété
une chanteuse absolument une
[Musique]
chanteuse ma mère m'a dit et ça j'en
suis sûre que j'avais vécu quand même 8
mois là-bas enfin bien sûr je suis pas
je suis né à Paris mais j'ai vécu
toute dans son ventre toute sa grossesse
là-bas donc pour moi déjà bon bien que
je sois né à Paris pour moi j'étais
tunisienne dès que je suis arrivé
j'étais tunisienne puis pu Tunis en fait
c'est c'est c'est comme un c'est comme
un rêve en fait que je fais tous les
soirs parce que mes parents c'est vrai
ils m'en ont parlé tellement reparlé et
puis leurs amis puis tout le monde enfin
tous les amis de mes parents parce que
c'est généralement que des Tunisiens il
me parle tellement de Tunis Tunis et
tout c'est comme si que je l'avais Ava
vécu mais en fait enfin j'ai mis une ou
deux fois les pieds mais j'ai jamais
vraiment habité là-bas ce que je me
souviens Tunis c'est un chameau rien des
cartes postales des photos et ce que
représente Tunis pour moi c'est avant
tout avant tout le P de mes parents
ensuite le pays où je suis né et enfin
un pays que je ne connais pas je ne te
cach pas un pays que je n'ai pas envie
de
connaître Laurent est-ce que tu as la
nostalgie de
Tunis nostalgie non mais j'ai la
nostalgie de la nostalgie de mes parents
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi c'estd que
finalement si je me promène dans la rue
que je vois une affiche de la Tunisie ça
me fait rien c'est un pays il est beau
il est pas beau bon c'est un pays mais
quand je vois mon père flasher
complètement là sur cette affiche et ma
mère s'assoir bon ça y est j'ai compris
bon la Tunisie je me rends compte ce que
ça peut ce que c'était ce que c'était
pour eux surtout donc finalement j'aime
la Tunisie à travers
eux chaque 5 minutes de la vie tu le
faites c'est ça que j'adore c'est ça qui
est fabuleux finalement d'aller acheter
un baignet ou d'aller boire un café
c'est une fête tout une fête rien n'est
banal plus rien est banal c'est ça qui
est
extraordinaire c'est qu'à Tunis a
tellement été pour nos parents les
clatard les amis les boouom les copains
et tout ça on dirait que si nous l'ont
transmis le gooutt de la
fête ils sont pratiquement tous partis
de leur gr et
finalement eux ce sont des déracin
nous nous sommes des implantés parce que
on est plus ou moins on s'aclimate plus
ou moins à la vie française et puis la
génération qui va
suivre qu' restera aucune
Trun moi je suis née à Tunis
Tunis je suis partie quand j'avais 1 an
62 toute ma famille est
partie
actuellement je sens cette la pression
finalement de du ce pays où je suis né
je la sens très fortement c'est d'autant
plus bizarre que je ne suis jamais
retourné depuis donc que j'avais un an
je suis plus jamais allée dans ce
pays je connais pas ce pays mais je sens
sa pression sur moi complètement bien
que j'en sois dissidente quand
même j'ai eu bon plusieurs expériences
j'ai connu beaucoup de choses beaucoup
de Milie
bon qui était qui avait rien à voir avec
le milieu juif tunisien mais il
n'empêche que finalement de temps en
temps j'avais besoin de retourner auprès
d'eux c'était comme en fait de de me
ressourcer un petit peu je j'étais
j'allais j'allais avec eux je sentais
une chaleur je sentais quelque chose que
je retrouvais nulle part ailleurs et bon
c'est des gens avec qui j'ai très peu
vécu mais mais qui malgré tout bon
m'apporte une chaleur que que je trouve
nulle part quoi que j'ai retrouvé nulle
part donc j'ai retournis vers eux d'une
façon intermittente et puis peu à peu je
me suis dit non finalement le monde
extérieur il est trop froid ils me
comprennent pas j'ai une sensibilité un
humour que des Européens ne peuvent pas
réellement comprendre bon je je sais pas
si ça vient des des racine juive ou ou
bien africaine ou le fait que jeis dans
un pays arabisant enfin bon je sais pas
vraiment d'où ça vient moi je comprends
pas trop je sais que je me retrouve en
Europe c'est encore une autre identité
qu'il faut
endosser bon donc j'ai essayé finalement
de me dire non finalement je suis juif
je suis tunisienne bon je vais avec eux
quoi je suis avec eux je suis des l'UR
il y a pas de problème bon paf ça a pas
marché ça a encore pas marché parce que
c'était toujours le même raisonnement au
bout du compte il me manquait quelque
chose donc tu te cherches tout le temps
je me cherche je me cherche j'arrête pas
de me chercher bon actuellement c'est
c'est c'est pareil parce que finalement
je suis je suis avec les des juifs
tunisiens bon je peux vraiment me marrer
comme je marre avec personne on voit des
matches de foot on fait une partie de
cartes bon il y a un humour une
exubérance qui a nulle part ailleurs
mais quand même il faut que je m'adapte
toujours il y a toujours un recentrage
même quand je suis avec eux maintenant
quand je suis avec un autre milieu que
soit le milieu intellectuel de faculté
ou le milieu du rock and roll que j'ai
pas mal enfin j'ai bien connu bon c'est
pareil je suis bien avec eux mais dans
une certaine limite je m'adapte tout le
temps je m'adapte à chaque fois je suis
dans une bon une incertitude à tous les
niveau qui est dû je crois à ses
origines qu'est-ce qui pourrait te
sécuriser je sais pas moi ce que je
voudrais finalement actuellement c'est
être bien
partout je crois que je sais pas si
c'est possible je sais pas si c'est un
handicap si c'est un avantage
mais je sais que j'ai j'ai besoin du
milieu juif tunisien et comme j'ai
besoin aussi d'un autre milieu de
quelque chose de de plus
complexe je su une individualité avant
avant de faire partie d'un groupe quand
[Musique]
même